(raptor screaming)
(wings thumping)
(trap snapping)
- Got him.
(dramatic music)
For as long as I can remember,
my life has been about one
thing: animals. (laughing)
Over the years, the animal
books turned into pets,
which turned into working
with bears in the wild.
This obsession has taken
me up into pine trees
and down into bear dens.
Hey, get back.
But I'd do anything for these animals,
and I know that I'm not alone.
(bold dramatic music)
Now, I'm on a mission.
I'm traveling across the country
to find young conservationists
driven by that same passion.
Oh, got a gator.
Wow.
We'll get up close and
personal with wildlife.
- Half cc ket.
- To discover how they fit
into the bigger picture.
- That needle ray did.
- All the way up.
- [Wes] I'll find the people
on the front lines of the fight
to understand our planet
and protect the animals
we share it with.
- When they squirm,
you don't grab a tail.
(sea lions barking)
- [Wes] And if it gets a
little messy along the way--
- [Woman] Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- [Wes] That's just part of the job.
I'm Wes Larson, this is Mission Wild.
(raptor screaming)
(tones chiming)